cadeau
trigano
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aussi près le jalouse je dois je faire
la tête
l'espagnol quand tu bouges les épaules
qu'elle jugeait
[Applaudissements]
non
olé
j'arrive
m
que jalouse
je crois qu'on va faire des petits duo
tous les deux ah ouais alors pour ceux
qui aiment les grandes voix la lega tout
ce que vous avez vu avant au niveau de
la chanson vous l'oubliez là ça va se
passer là ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la musique
un bouton s'est couché
histoire
alors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour lui
en andalousie et donc pendant qu'on se
rende à nous
il ya donc notre belle andalouse qui va
rentrer on va accueillir notre andalouse
l'afrique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il a pas voulu être la robe
je
non
m
baby dans les mots
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci
et vous quel but
[Musique]